Vamos a resolver otro de estos entretenidos
problemas de edad.
Y el siguiente problema dice esto,
Vicente tiene 4 veces la edad de Alex.
Hace 12 años, Vicente tenía 7 veces la edad de Alex.
¿Qué edad tiene Alex actualmente?
Y bueno, estaría muy bien que tú intentaras
resolverlo primero, por ti mismo,
sin ver el video, porque a continuación
voy a dar la solución.
Entonces lo primero que voy a hacer es preguntarme que quiero, y lo que quiero es la edad de Alex
actualmente, por lo tanto vamos a definir, con una cierta variable la edad de Alex.
Voy a suponer "b", "b" es la edad de Alex
actualmente, justo ahora, entonces
sea "b" la edad de Alex justo ahora y voy a hacer esto con la mayor formalidad posible.
Si yo tuviera un problema así en un examen,
haría justo esto,
lo primero que haría es una tabla,
¿qué tabla?
Primero me voy a fijar en la edad de Alex
y en la edad de Vicente,
así que déjame poner aquí, Alex y acá abajo Vicente...
Vicente, muy bien...
y hay dos fechas importantes en este problema,
¿qué fechas?
Bueno, la primera es lo que pasa justo ahora,
es decir, hoy, vamos a ponerle aquí,
lo que pasa hoy o lo que pasa actualmente...
lo que pasa hoy...
y la otra fecha importante, es lo que pasó
hace 12 años...
hace 12 años, ¿qué fue lo que pasó?
Bueno, vamos a fijarnos primero en la edad
que tiene Alex actualmente.
Alex actualmente pues tiene "b" años, es
justo como habíamos definido a "b"...
Alex actualmente tiene "b" años,
¿y qué pasaba con Alex hace 12 años?
Bueno, pues hace 12 años Alex tenía pues
la edad que tiene actualmente menos 12 años,
es decir, "b" menos 12.
Muy bien, ya sabemos perfectamente que onda
con Alex, al menos en variables,
vamos a fijarnos ahora en Vicente.
¿Vicente qué edad tiene actualmente?
Bueno, fíjate en esta oración, aquí está
lo importante de este problema,
Vicente tiene 4 veces la edad de Alex...
actualmente Vicente tiene 4 veces la edad
de Alex, es decir que si Alex tiene "b" años, Vicente tiene 4 veces "b", 4 veces su edad, muy bien.
¿Y qué edad tenía Vicente hace 12 años?
Pues suena muy lógico, Vicente tenía la
edad que tiene ahorita -12 años, exactamente
igual que lo qué le pasó a Alex,
entonces "4b" menos 12.
Muy bien, hasta aquí espero que vayamos todo
en orden, porque viene el paso más importante.
Vamos a fijarnos en qué dice esta oración.
Hace 12 años Vicente tenía, pues lo que
sabemos es "4b" menos 12, pero además
nos dicen que desde otra perspectiva, Vicente tenía 7 veces la edad que tenía Alex hace 12 años,
es decir, 7 veces esta edad y por
lo tanto si yo multiplico esta edad por 7,
podemos llegar a una ecuación.
Aquí está lo importante de este problema, hace 12 años Vicente tenía 7 veces la edad de Alex,
es decir, que si Vicente hace 12
años tenía "4b" menos 12, esto tiene que
ser igual a la edad de Alex que tenía hace
12 años por 7, es decir, 7 por "b" menos 12,
vamos a escribirlo aquí.
7 que multiplica a "b" menos 12 es decir,
la edad que tenía Alex hace 12 años multiplicada
por 7 tiene que ser igual a la edad que tenía
Vicente hace 12 años, es decir, "4b" menos 12
y ya tengo una ecuación con solamente una incógnita.
Por lo tanto de aquí puedo despejar a "b"
y lo primero que voy a hacer es distribuir
la multiplicación por este 7, este 7 multiplica
a todo lo que está dentro del paréntesis,
es decir, 7 multiplica a "b" y 7 multiplica a -12.
7 por "b" es "7b" y 7 por -12 es -84, "7b"
menos 84 esto es igual a "4b" menos 12...
"4b" menos 12, ¡muy bien!
Y bueno, como quiero a las "b" positivas,
lo que voy a hacer es dejar todo lo que tengo
que ver con "b" de este lado de la ecuación,
del lado izquierdo y para esto, lo que voy
a hacer es restar "4b" de ambos lados de la
ecuación, es decir, "-4b"...
"-4b" y entonces, ¿qué me queda?
Bueno, primero, "-4b" y "4b" se cancelan,
"4b" menos "4b" se van y solamente me queda -12
y del lado izquierdo me queda, "7b" menos
"4b" esto es "3b", "3b" menos 84.
Muy bien, y ahora lo que voy a hacer es sumar
84 de ambos lados de la ecuación para que
me quede "3b" solamente de un lado de la ecuación.
Así que voy a sumar 84 del lado izquierdo,
84 del lado derecho, estos dos se van,
del lado izquierdo solamente me queda "3b", perfecto...
mientras que del lado derecho,
¿qué me va a quedar?
Es 84 menos 12, 84 menos 12 es 72, perfecto, 72.
"3b" es igual a 72 y ahora voy a dividir ambos
lados de la ecuación entre 3,
de tal manera que 3 y 3 se van y solamente me queda "b", "b" es igual a 72 entre 3, que según yo...
bueno, no soy calculadora humana pero creo que es 24.
Es más, vamos a corroborarlo, vamos a ver si sí es 24.
72 entre 3...
3 cabe dos veces en 7, 2 por 3 es 6,
7 menos 6 es 1 y bajo el 2 y después dice 4, perfecto,
4 por 3 es 12 entonces "b" vale 24...
¡y ya está!
ya tengo lo que yo quería, la edad de Alex,
Alex tiene 24 años en la actualidad...
en la actualidad Alex tiene 24 años.
Muy bien, pero ahora vamos a completar la tabla.
Vicente tenía 4 veces la edad de Alex actualmente
y 4 por 24 es 96, es decir, que Vicente actualmente
tiene 96 años, es decir que podría ser su
abuelo o tal vez alguna de las personas de
la tercera edad con las que juega ajedrez,
no lo sé...
Y bueno, lo que sé, es que Vicente hace 12 años...
hace 12 años Vicente tenía 84 años,
96 menos 12 es 84,
hace 12 años Vicente tenía 7 veces la edad de Alex.
Alex hace 12 años tenía 12 años porque
24 menos 12 es 12
y 12 por 7 es 84, por lo tanto concuerda todo.